bonjour claude bonjour ravi de vous
avoir sur ce plateau de la matinale
alors ce rendez-vous avorté entre
l'union européenne et l'iran n'était pas
le signe d'un recul de l'iran finalement
l'iran était prêt
écoutez le nouveau gouvernement irakien
celui qui a été nommé par le président
raïssi qu'il en fût dire plus dur que
l'ancien a dit qu'il voulait reprendre
le chemin de la négociation de vienne et
qu'il leur prendrait d'ailleurs à
préciser mes affaires étrangères iranien
avant le mois de novembre grâce assez
peu de temps la semaine dernière
l'adjoint de monsieur beaux rêves
enrique mora s'est rendu à téhéran pour
explorer les voies de la reprise de la
négociation et il a entendu les iraniens
lui dire eh bien si nous continuons la
conversation à bruxelles la semaine
prochaine et effectivement le pataquès
d'hier et que découle du fait que le
gouvernement
iranien le ministère des affaires
étrangères iranien a dit que son
négociateur serait à bruxelles lundi
prenant manifestement monsieur morel de
cours monsieur morel qui peut-être
peut-être considère que les temps ne
sont pas mûrs pour qu'ils se mettre en
avant dans cette négociation notamment
par rapport aux autres partenaires
c'est-à-dire aux six états signataires
de l'accord du 15 juillet sur le
nucléaire
sur le nucléaire iranien donc monsieur
morel avis mais moi je n'ai rendez vous
avec personne et par conséquent je ne
recevrai pas jeudi prochain l'émissaire
le négociateur iranien ça ressemble un
petit peu un pataquès les iraniens
manifestement souhaite avancer parce
qu'ils ont besoin économiquement de la
levée des sanctions mais il ne souhaite
pas payer le prix fort pour cette levée
des sanctions américaines et des nations
unies et par conséquent ils disent nous
nous voulons retourner à l'accord qui
avait été signé initialement rien de
plus aucun engagement supplémentaire or
il est clair que les américains
voudraient un petit peu plus alors
justement dans ce couac diplomatique les
américains paraissent bien silencieux
alors pourquoi donc alors ils sont bien
silencieux mais ils agissent
naturellement en coulisses c'est aussi
la diplomatie monsieur morel je crois
était la semaine dernière
à washington
monsieur blinken a aussi reçu son
homologue saoudien et on a entendu
monsieur blinken dire que à washington
toutes les options étaient sur la table
alors c'est la fameuse expression quand
on dit que toutes les options sont sur
la table ça veut dire y compris l'option
militaire donc letombe radio s'est durci
à washington le ton s'est durci parce
que le temps passe et finalement cet
accord avait été conclu pour une durée
de temps limitée donc si par miracle à
négociations de vienne aboutissait la
durée d'application de cet accord serait
finalement assez courte et donc là les
américains ont peut être un point qui
est pourquoi ne pas engager la
discussion sur ce qui se passera après
et plus c'est évidemment les autres
sujets d autres sujets que les
américains voudraient voir discuter à
savoir le balistique qui n'est pas
couvert par l'accord et
l'action de l'iran dans l'arc iranien
l'arc chiite dans les pays dans les pays
voisins et là-dessus naturellement les
rangs ne veut pas en entendre parler
c'est le retour pur et simple à l'accord
initial et rien de plus alors est-ce
qu'il faut être optimiste ou pessimiste
je ne le sait pas assez trop tôt il est
probable que en effet la négociation
reprendra à vienne mais comme vous le
savez c'est un petit peu compliqué la
chorégraphie est un petit pétrolier
puisque les américains ne sont pas
formellement à la table de négociation
sont derrière les rideaux et que bien
entendu il négocie aussi avec tout le
monde et que les européens sont un peu
aussi leurs représentants même si les
européens sont extrêmement désireux
d'aboutir à un accord et puis il ya
aussi naturellement la russie et la
chine la chine qui est on n'en parle pas
beaucoup mais le premier partenaire
économique
de l'iran qui a conclu au printemps
dernier un accord de coopération pour 25
ans pour construire beaucoup
d'infrastructures en iran et qui
probablement
et plus compréhensive que d'autres
vis-à-vis de téhéran il ne reste pas
beaucoup de temps que vous pariez des
américains derrière le rideau dans cette
pièce de théâtre l'iran est au centre
sous l'influencé d'un côté des français
et des allemands et de l'autre côté soul
influence sino-russe quelle est la marge
de manoeuvre de l'allemagne et de la
france dans cette affaire finalement
marché mais elle est assez faible elle
est assez fait d'autant plus qu'il y à
d'autres acteurs qui ne sont pas
naturellement dans la table de
négociation et notamment israël israël
dont chacun sait que le premier ministre
monsieur bennett comme son prédécesseur
ne veut à aucun prix du retour de cet
accord et il le dit haut et fort il le
dit à la knesset il le dit à washington
il le dit à paris le 10 à berlin et le
dit partout et c'est évidemment un
élément qui vient compliquer la
négociation et qui vient renforcer les
propos de monsieur blinken selon le
selon lesquelles toutes les options
seraient sur la table à washington donc
il y aura certainement une reprise des
négociations
parce que le nouveau gouvernement ne
veut pas assumer la responsabilité de
l'échec et et vis-à-vis de sa population
la responsabilité de la non levée des
sanctions mais il est peu probable que
ceux ci avancent très vite d'ici la fin
de l'année merci beaucoup que l'autre
gauche maison pour votre éclairage ce
matin l'édito diplo c'est tous les
mardis matin dans la matinale de rtl
france merci club